well good evening welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the administration's
efforts to secure the American border
and enforce federal law are running into
a surprising group of critics American
governors the administration wants to
deploy up to 4,000 National Guard troops
on the Mexican border to assist border
patrol operations but National Guard
troops are ordinarily under the control
of state governors and some of them
don't like it oregon governor Kate brown
says if the president asks for her Guard
troops she will refuse Montana governor
Stephen Bullock said the same in normal
circumstances the first duty of the
military is national defense and that
begins with securing a country's
frontiers but in the u.s. that Duty has
been sacrificed on the altar of
political game
martin O'Malley is the former Democratic
governor of the state of Maryland we
just spoke to him hey governor thanks
for joining us I'm Hugh Tucker so a
question about precedent in in 2010
President Obama authorized operation
phalanx which sent National Guardsmen
local units to the southwest border
President Bush did the same thing in
2006 and as I remember at the time
governors Republican and Democrat thank
them for the help why is this different
well this is different for a couple of
reasons and in a way it's not different
I mean honestly what I think President
Obama learned by the deployment of
National Guard troops and that
re-election year 2010 was that it wasn't
very effective it was very expensive and
he probably could have accomplished the
same ends by by other means so he did
not do it again
I think the question to ask in this
deployment is is this really addressing
an American security need or is it
political theater and there always
whether President Bush or President
Obama are now President Trump any use of
federal troops even National Guard
troops within the continental United
States has to pass certain tests that we
are put into national law that prohibits
the use of federal troops for law
enforcement
this is so I mean I I just want to make
sure I understand it so you're saying
that Democratic governors in Oregon for
example in Montana have done a cost
analysis of this and they're just
against wasting federal money they just
they part of them dies when they see
federal dollars going to waste is that
that's the objection oh I have no idea I
mean I I haven't I'm not sure which
governors are saying this is a good idea
and which is not all I know is that when
it was done under President Obama in
2010 in hindsight I think most everybody
agreed it was a wasteful use of dollars
and it was not necessary now there
probably will be some governor's who
might find that they are very supportive
and you know the incumbent governor of
Arizona or someplace in using their own
National Guard there within their state
to support federal you know protection
of the border I'm not saying it can't be
done but what I'm saying is that when it
was done in the past it was found to be
ineffective wasteful and and many people
observe that it was a step or two too
close to violating the principles of the
Posse Comitatus Act which says that we
should never allow federal troops unless
we could if we can avoid it to be used
for law enforcement purposes I mean from
Little Rock in 1957 to the universe
Mississippi I think it's 61 I'm going to
let Washington DC in 68 April fifty
years ago this month federal troops were
used because you know there was a law
enforcement crisis I think Hurricane
Katrina hurricane therefore that a
collapse of civilian things yeah it's
you know I was I served as the co-chair
of the Council of Governors and in that
that was created by an act of Congress
to meet quarterly with the Secretary of
Defense and Secretary of Homeland
Security to work out these issues each
of those examples you give Tucker are
indeed you know important historic
precedents all of which have to do with
making sure that we don't use federal
troops for law enforcement purposes
within the United States a long-standing
principle from this for public space
right but this wouldn't be of course
this would be they're deeply about right
but that's I mean
that as real as you know this has to do
with support that the Democratic Party
now has affirmative leaf or illegal
immigration they don't want any steps
taken meaningful ones to stop it they
don't acknowledge it's a problem these
are new positions for the Democratic
Party Bill Clinton did not hold these
views Hillary Clinton didn't hold these
use two years ago but if you're honest
you got away by are that the views of
the party have changed and you've
forgotten that litany to mention that
President Obama probably deported and
interned more immigrants than any
president de Hedstrom so I don't accept
your I don't accept your premise with
with respect I don't accept your premise
that the Democratic Party is in favor of
illegal immigration flooding the country
with drugs or bringing in rapists or
murderers fled the country drugs are
rapists or anything like that you're
overstating it I do think they're
opposed to any meaningful attempt to
stopping the inflow of immigration into
America and I think it's actually very
hard for Democrats right now to concede
that 11 million illegals in your country
is a problem do you think it's a problem
I don't believe that the level of
immigration even some total is much
greater than it's been at other times in
our nation's history and in fact that's
order crossing in Mexico as you know
Tucker boarding crossings in Mexico are
at about a forty six year low actually
apprehensions of illegal immigrants are
up three times this month over this
month last year
so in fact they're up yes but overall
boarding crossings are down I'm terribly
the apprehension of illegal aliens into
this country but my country
let's give Donald Trump victory Donald
Trump everything
see that's the distractors worked the 46
year low okay the question I'm sorry 11
million illegal aliens at least in this
country right now right you think that's
right I need to do something about it
right anything short of giving them
citizenship and voting rights 6 sending
them home would that be acceptable to
you well I think some of them probably
should be home but the sent so-called
home but the bad
majority of them probably should not be
they should be given a pathway to
citizenship and we should engage in
comprehensive immigration reform as we
have in other periods in our one a 1% in
realize 11 millions a lot of people what
percentage do you think ought to be
given citizenship look I think it's
certainly anybody that's a serious
threat to to public safety I mean I
think that they should be returned and
and deported and in fact that's what we
have been doing as a country for some
time but I think the vast majority of
those 11 million people Tucker or you
know we're not going to be transporting
or deporting them home I mean maybe you
just might wheels made my case and maybe
some will go home of your case I'm glad
my my case that the previous Democratic
presidents including Bill Clinton said
it is a prima facie problem to have 11
million people here illegally we should
I agree stop the inflow and we should
make them leave because we didn't admit
them in the first place and that used to
be the position of the Democratic Party
I'm not sure that the make them all
leave thing is something that you can
say is a a realistic policy would be
cost-effective or will ultimately be
good for our nation especially if many
of those people are kids that have only
known the United States so I'm not
attacking I'm just saying you're making
my point that the position has changed
over the party and I just like a reality
check once in a while to acknowledge
that governor thank you for joining us
after Thank You Tucker land of the free
home of the brave